a long time has passed but the pole
let's are distraught by what happened to
their son were at eight years ago Murat
left his home in Istanbul to do his
military service he never returned he
died in an army barrack the victim of a
brutal beating we sent our son to serve
the fatherland and the fatherland killed
him he didn't fall in conflict or
fighting Kurdish separatists he was
killed by fellow soldiers they stomped
on him his body was covered with boot
marks it was horrendous maurette was
accused of theft and in custody he was
subjected to hours of beating on the
orders of a superior officer the
soldiers responsible were later let off
with a fine now moretz parents want
justice what that is choke come on Oscar
they get he still had everything ahead
of him walk every didn't make society he
wanted to start a business and have a
family and take care of us when we got
old well they thought Allah cut his time
short and took him what else can I say
in mid-march a group of soldiers
families rallied in front of parliament
in Ankara cane and Polat was among them
they're outraged at how slowly such
crimes are investigated for decades
verbal and physical abuse and suicide in
the Turkish army was a taboo topic now
victims and their families dare to go
public we sent our brother to do
military service and what did they do
they killed him and I ask you has that
ever happened to the child of a
parliamentarian or the son of a rich
family human rights organizations
accused the army of hushing up
suspicious deaths by making them look
like suicides they say more soldiers
have died in their own barracks and
fighting rebels from the separatist
Kurdistan Workers Party every Turkish
male must serve 15 months draft
conscientious objection isn't allowed in
school children learned that every Turk
is a born soldier military culture has a
long tradition in Turkey the founder of
the Turkish Republic Kemal Ataturk was
himself an army general but today the
military has lost a lot of its political
clout and grievances that were long
suppressed and now finally being aired
merch Ava's did his military service in
the provinces of Anatolia to this day
he's haunted by his experiences there
recently he filed a complaint with the
human rights parliamentary commission
Turkish nationalists view his action as
tantamount to treason even speaking to
us is a risk in Turkey it's a crime to
say anything that could harm the
reputation of the army Ostler yup
m'little getty corporal punishment was
normal as you didn't do your duties or
perform them to a less than satisfactory
standard it all
citral share were comrades who were
subjected to sleep deprivation Brooklyn
and if they fell asleep later on duty
they'd be punished again I saw it go to
dodge the car / them oh cool look Adam
it was quite normal for officer cadets
to be allowed to humiliate the new
recruits so does stole candy city mr.
call waltz they were always exploiting
their lot yeah and even forcing them to
make breakfast they were their personal
service upon be hard he's me chudai ki r
us an initiative for soldiers rights was
founded in Istanbul and in just the
first eight months it received nearly a
thousand requests for help the activists
are demanding an ombudsman for the
soldiers much like Germany's
Commissioner for the armed forces in
Colombia every year four hundred
thousand young men are cooped up
together for 15 months and the only
choice they have is to be a victim or to
take part in the abuse and humiliation
in one way or another it's systemic and
that has got to be broken with the
cooler cooling most of the victims of
abuse and suicides in the Turkish Armed
Forces are members of ethnic minorities
or come from poor backgrounds mourad
Pollard grew up in a poor neighborhood
in Istanbul
his father Keenan runs a little tea shop
eight years after his son's death he's
still fighting for justice he is going
to the European Court of Human Rights to
force the military brass to admit their
complicity and he wants the case against
moretz accused killers reopened I won't
rest until the death of my son is atoned
for until those responsible for it and
no longer running around free and until
the state recognizes my son as a fallen
martyr as a student mirchi Ava's
generally had little to worry about in
the barracks his fellow soldiers were
aware that he was able to take legal
action if they tried anything the cruel
hazings in the barracks left a stain on
his image of the so-called heroic
Turkish military and they left memories
of torment that still haunt him she
distribution longitudal they always
justify rush treatment in the army with
the fight against terrorism they stick
to our new road almost sure but now a
peace process has been initiated with
the Kurds to the heart shield that could
be an opportunity for us to ensure that
Turkey has normal humane military
service in the future you please Harley
the courage of family members and
witnesses like merge Chavez has
triggered a public debate a debate that
may save the lives of future soldiers in
Turkey
you